what is up everybody at Santa Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the single biggest secret
in attack on Titan the one mystery that
ties everything else together and the
one missing piece that can explain all
of the burning unanswered questions in
the attack on Titan anime and manga I am
referring to the greatest power in all
of attack on Titan the power that makes
Titan transformations memory
manipulation and all the other
supernatural aspects of the series
possible and if you haven't guessed
already in this video I will be breaking
down everything that we know about the
paths the coordinate and the progenitor
amir fritz in order to unravel the
biggest mystery in the series a mystery
that has been solved for nearly 2000
years if you enjoyed the attack on titan
content on this channel and you want to
see more you can leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and turn on all notifications
so you never miss another attack on
titan upload a big shoutout to the anime
our patrons who make videos like this
one possible i'll talk a bit more about
them at the end of this video but now
let's get into it just remember there
will be spoilers in this video I will be
delving into all the latest developments
in the attack on Titan story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned the paths are arguably the single
biggest unknown in attack on titan and
as the story has progressed we as the
readers and viewers have been learning
about them at the same time as the main
characters in the story these paths lie
at the center of everything including
the origins of titan powers the true
identity of amir fritz and all the time
and space bending phenomenon that we
have been witnessing in attack on titan
so what do we know about these paths so
far we know that these are supernatural
channels that connect every LDN
including titans to each other all the
paths come together at the coordinate
and this coordinate is the founding
titan power this means that the founding
titan is directly connected to all LD
ins also known as the subjects of ameer
and as a result when the founding titan
power is possessed by someone with royal
blood
this person can alter the memories of
aliens
change their physical composition turned
them into Titans and so on the paths can
somehow transport things instantly
through space and seemingly even through
time on top of somehow being able to
transport physical objects such as flesh
and bones whenever a titan
transformation occurs the paths can also
transfer memories for example the
memories of previous Titan shifters will
be passed on to the current Titan
shifter after he inherits that specific
power for some reason how well the
memories are transferred from one
shifter to another depends on how close
they are to the previous shifter if the
two are blood related such as Griffin
Aran the memories will be clearer but if
the two individuals are unrelated the
memories will be much less clear as an
additional example we know that whenever
a member of the royal bloodline inherits
the founding titan power they become
bound by the vow of pacifism however if
someone who does not have royal blood
inherits the founder the vow of pacifism
does not have any effect on them while
we know that the paths connect all LD
ends or subjects of Emir to the
coordinate and while we know that other
nations like Marlins are ordinary humans
who are not connected by these paths the
Ackermann clan who are our minority
bloodline are also connected to each
other by some type of path as a result
whenever an acraman goes through their
awakening they inherit the battle
experience of all of the other
Ackerman's who lived before them for
example it is clear to me curses own
awakening back when she was still a
child involved paths her awakening is
clearly followed by the same type of
lightning esque visual effect that
accompanies titan transformations this
is because the Ackermann clan is a
byproduct of titan science we first
learned this in chapter 93 of the manga
although it is not immediately clear
what this means exactly over the course
of the story it is revealed that in the
past the Ackerman's were a clan of elite
fighters who served as the bodyguards to
the royal Fritz family so it is implied
that similar technology or magic
whichever it is that was used to create
the Titans was also used to create the
Ackerman's however although the
Ackerman's are definitely connected to
each other by paths these paths appear
to be distinct from the ones connecting
all
subjects of Emir to the founding Titan
as a result the founding Titan cannot
turn the Ackerman's into titans
or manipulate their memories in any way
it has been clearly established that the
paths are invisible networks that
somehow transcend physical space but
over the course of the story it has
become apparent that the paths transcend
time as well for example the owl errant
Krueger had memories of Mikasa and Armin
before they were even born on top of
that in chapter 1 20 when Zeek and Aaron
take a trip through grisha's memories
Grisha is able to sense and actually see
Zeek as an adult this means that many
years ago grish I had an experience in
which he saw a glimpse of Zeek from the
future which again proves that the past
can transcend time and that as a result
of the paths the future can have a
direct effect on the past in recent
chapters of the attack on titans story a
lot more information was revealed about
the paths the coordinate and amir fritz
although more information will likely
come out in the future we must discuss
all of the new information right here
because some of this changes everything
we thought we knew about the history of
the LD ends and the world of attack on
Titan in Chapter 120 Ahrens head is
severed from his body by Gabi's bullet
Zeke manages to make contact with the
head and because Zeek has royal blood
and Aaron has the founding Titan power
the two of them are transported to an
unknown land a place that is seemingly
beyond space and time this land is
seemingly covered with sand or some
other type of soft soil and the paths
are shown as a great pillar of light
rising up into the sky and branching out
like a giant tree according to Zeke he
felt as if he was there for years
waiting for Aaron to awaken but at the
same time he also feels like it's only
been an instant it is then revealed that
a young girl inhabits this place and
Zeke believes this to be a mere fritz
herself however based on everything that
we've known up to this point we believed
that Emir fritz was a great leader of
the LDN people she was the progenitor
who possessed all nine Titan powers and
established the vast LD an empire
according to LDN legend she was a
benevolent goddess and a
- Marlon history she was an evil
devilish creature but no matter who you
ask
Ahmir Fritz was believed to be an
incredibly powerful and influential
ruler nevertheless all of these beliefs
and stories are turned upside down in
Chapter one xx as Zeke says that the
Emir Fritz who inhabits the unknown land
the land which seems to serve as the
visual representation of the coordinate
is actually a slave with no will of her
own
Zeke believes that Amir is just a slave
compelled to obey the fritz royal family
and he thinks that all members of the
royal family who inherit the founding
Titan power come to this unknown land in
order to command Emir Fritz to do their
bidding so for example when Carl fritz
decided to manipulate the memories of
all LD ends and parodies he came to this
unknown land and commanded Emir to make
it happen Zeke also speculates that
whenever anyone transforms into a Titan
Amir sculpts the Titan right here out of
this special soil but because this place
seems to be outside of time and space
the Titan transformation appears to take
place instantly within the physical
world as of chapter 120 it appears that
Zeke is the only one who can command
Amir as a result of his royal blood even
though the power of the founding Titan
currently resides with him Eren he
cannot command Amir because he doesn't
have royal blood but because he came
here without actually having the power
of the founding Titan within him but
instead he entered this place because he
came into contact with Aaron's blood
Zeke was apparently able to overcome the
vow of pacifism which restrains all
other holders of the founding Titan with
royal blood and while our information on
Emir Fritz and the coordinate is by no
means complete the fact that Zeke is
able to overcome the valve pacifism is a
huge reveal also the fact that he mere
fritz
the legendary progenitor is actually a
slave without a will of her own is
shocking to say the least I still don't
quite believe it personally I think that
this Amir who is a slave and who no
longer has a will of her own may just be
one part of Amir fritz some small part
of her that didn't die when her physical
body died but I find it hard to believe
that the legendary Amir was always
nothing but a slave although if that is
then it is clear that everything we
think we know about the history of the
attack on Titan world is completely
wrong we now know that all LD ins are
connected by the paths we know that all
these paths come together at the
coordinate and we know that the
coordinates visual representation is an
unknown land beyond space and time which
features a giant tree-like pillar of
light and Amir frits who seemingly
wanders without a will of her own and
uses the soil to construct and
reconstruct Titans because the paths
transcend both space and time
Titan transformations are able to
violate the laws of science by allowing
physical material to be transported
instantly from the unknown land to
wherever the transformation is taking
place physically we also know that there
are separate ackerman paths which
connect the battle experiences of all
past Ackerman's to the currently living
ones but these paths are not directly
linked to the paths that connect the
ldiots it appears that only those with
royal blood can use the founding titan
power because Amir obeys only members of
the Royal for its family and it also
appears that the vow of pacifism can be
avoided if someone with royal blood is
able to enter the unknown land without
actually possessing the founding Titan
power basically if they can reach the
coordinate by making direct contact with
someone else who has the founding Titan
power and in Zeke's case this is eren
yeager but there is still a lot that we
don't know such as how Amir Fritz became
a slave without a will of her own and
how the paths were created in the first
place was it some sort of ancient magic
ritual that created them was it a
fantastical science experiment or was it
really a divine being like the earth
devil who gave the power to Amir as
legend suggests and if so who in the
world was this earth devil and where is
this creature now we will likely get a
lot more information in the coming
months and if we do get some major
reveals I will definitely make an update
video but for now I want to bring
everyone's attention to something as you
may or may not know attack on Titan is
full of direct references to Norse
mythology and even the name Amir
comes from Norse mythology in which Amir
is a primeval being and the progenitor
of the Ahtna
who are sometimes referred to as the
Giants it's
to see the direct similarity between the
norse amir and the giants any mere fritz
and the titans but beyond that i believe
that the tree of light that we saw in
chapter 120 is a direct reference to
each Drossel the mythical World Tree in
Norse mythology that connects the nine
worlds think about it in Nordic legends
big Drossel is basically the coordinate
that connects the nine worlds of Norse
mythology and an attack on titan the
tree like coordinate connects all the
subjects of amir and just like there are
nine worlds in Norse mythology there are
nine Titan shifter powers in attack on
Titan on top of that in Norse mythology
there are beings called gnomes these are
female Giants who control destiny or
fate the three most important of the
gnomes are believed to stand at the well
of fate
they draw water from the well and take
the sand that lies around it and then
they pour the water and the sand over
the Yggdrasil tree so that its branches
will not rot these three gnomes are
described as powerful made in giant
esses your tune whose arrival from
Jotunheim ended the Golden Age of the
gods the domain of these norms
transcends time because they control
destiny and destiny includes the past
the present and the future so we have
these timeless giant SS who draw water
and sand and pour it over Ignacio and we
have Ameer Fritz who dwells in the
unknown land beyond time and space and
uses water and some type of sand to
construct the bodies of the Titans to me
personally these similarities are pretty
stunning and since it is clear that
attack on Titan is heavily inspired by
Norse mythology we can look to Norse
mythology for potential clues for how
the story of attack on Titan will
ultimately end Hajime isayama has
mentioned multiple times that the story
of attack on Titan is a tragic one and
what is more befitting of such a
description in Norse mythology than
Ragnarok
the prophecy of an apocalyptic series of
events that will lead to a great war to
the deaths of many including gods
themselves and to natural disasters that
will destroy the entire world
after these cataclysmic events the world
will be renewed and two human survivors
will repopulate the earth once again
although we've always known that attack
on Titan is heavily influenced by Norse
mythology these most recent revelations
about the paths the coordinate the
unknown land and Namir Fritz really
emphasized the connection between attack
on Titan and Nordic mythology we will
have to wait and see how the series
eventually ends and although I am sure
that we will see a lot more stunning
twists and revelations before the end if
I was asked to predict how attack on
Titan would end the first thing I would
look to would be Ragnarok we can expect
a lot of death and destruction perhaps
the death of the gods themselves or
their equivalent an attack on Titan
which is of course the Titans and Emir
fritz and then finally a sliver of hope
for a new and better world will emerge
after a lot of destruction and suffering
but that is my opinion let me know what
you guys think
what other revelations do you think that
we will get about the paths and aamir
Fritz and how do you think that the
story of attack on Titan will ultimately
end let me know down in the comments I
always like hearing from you if you
enjoyed the attack on Titan content on
this channel and you want to see more
you can leave a like to let me know and
if you're new to anime uproar please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell I want to give a huge
thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons for supporting our work and
making our work possible a special thank
you to all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
zelgius and on Hell crews another
massive thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray ace
ingrid ah al Olin Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun and Keylong and finally at
the very pinnacle of interdimensional
greatness a tier reserved only for
legends a massive thank you to Reagan
Harrison and Lord naksan or disciples Oh
Lord to ego himself if you feel that our
content provides value for you when you
want to support more be sure to check
out our patreon link in the description
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]